[Musik]
ja und in berlin grüße ich jetzt den
chef der eisenbahnergewerkschaft
gdl claus weselsky hallo guten morgen
herr weselsky was müsste denn passieren
damit sie an den verhandlungstisch mit
der bahn zurück kehren
nun ein ende der trickserei des
bahnvorstandes müsste eintreten die
haben bis einschließlich jetzt ihre
position vom 7 juni nicht verändert und
haben sowohl mit den vertretern als auch
der öffentlichkeit vorgegaukelt dass sie
ständig in bewegung sind klare botschaft
wir haben keine laufzeit von 40 monaten
akzeptiert die verhandlungen sind am 7
juni genau mit dieser prämisse
gescheitert bis einschließlich heute hat
die arbeitgeberseite in der frage der
laufzeit keine bewegung gemacht in der
frage der korona prämie nichts denn eine
corona prämie anzubieten ist kein
angebot im sinne von tarifverhandlungen
und vor allen dingen hat die bahn sich
nicht bewegt und auch nicht zugestanden
dass die betriebsrente fortgesetzt wird
die den eisenbahner und die kleine
renten kürzen soll ja herr wir selbst
gehe nun gibt es kommentatoren die sagen
das ist zwar die richtige sache wird die
sie da eintreten aber sie persönlich
seien der falsche anwalt dafür ich sage
nochmal vielleicht vorgestern ihre ihre
geschichten die sie erzählt mit
hochbegabten city wo sie den bahnchef
angesprochen haben also ganz persönlich
oder was er sage da haben sie erklärt
vor der presse des g ihn am steiß vorbei
liegt vielleicht an solchen
formulierungen herr lutz hat ja auch
reagiert und hat gesagt achter werden
wunden geschlagen die nur schlecht
heilen können und das wäre gift für die
zusammengehörigkeit im unternehmen ich
sag mal das ist sehr schwierig nach
solchen persönlichen sachen dass man
sich dann noch mal zusammenfinden kann
oder
da muss ich leider widersprechen es ist
nicht schwierig wir sind alle sehr
professionell und wir sprechen wenn es
denn etwas zu besprechen gibt auch auf
augenhöhe miteinander das was hier im
hintergrund läuft ist eine riesengroße
propaganda maschinerie die die bahn in
gang gesetzt hat und sie so dafür dass
zb der vorsitzende der gewerkschaft in
deutschland zu bezeichnet wird wie er
bezeichnet wird und da sage ich mal ganz
offen ich gehöre nicht zu denen die
events auf die linke wange einige knallt
kriegen die rechte auch hinhalten da
gibt es zurück punkt aber herr lutz
beschwört die eisenbahner familie und
ich sage ihnen ganz offen die
eisenbahner familie gibt es schon lange
nicht mehr und zwar seitdem wir von
verwaltungen von führungskräften
überschwemmt werden und wo menschen die
von eisenbahn keine ahnung haben unseren
kolleginnen und kollegen die im leben
lang diesen beruf und dieser profession
nachgehen beibringen wollen wie die
eisenbahn schneller besser laufen kann
und sie schaffen es nicht und das ist
das eigentliche grundproblem hier hatten
die weselsky und problem mit dem
arbeitgeber db ag sondern wir haben
mittlerweile 10.000 streikteilnehmer in
der letzten maßnahme 10.000 kolleginnen
und kollegen dieses arbeitgebers gehen
in den streik und nie weil ich
persönlichen problemen habe sondern weil
sie davon überzeugt sind dass diese
arbeitgeber nachgeben muss und die
vernünftig für entlohnen und vor allen
dingen deren betriebsrente wieder in
kraft setzen muss nun ich habe vorher
schon was gesagt zu den meinungsumfragen
also es haben immer weniger leute
verständnis dafür es sind noch ferien
zum beispiel in sachsen in baden
württemberg in bayern und fünf tage das
ist eine mächtig lange zeit
können sie das verstehen dass die leute
sagen wir sind es jetzt langsam
zunehmend genervt das ist der dritte
streik im august und jetzt noch fünf
tage
ja ich habe verständnis für die menschen
die eigentlich mit den zügen reisen
unternehmen wollen oder zur arbeit
fahren wollen aber ich sage auch wir
haben zwei arbeitskämpfe gemacht jeweils
48 stunden im personenverkehr und das
management lässt sich nicht ansatzweise
beeindrucken oder bewegen in richtung
eines verbesserten angebot ist deswegen
ist es zwangsläufig dass in der weiteren
maßnahmen erfolgt und ich sage auch ganz
offen das eisenbahnsystem dass wir
schützen wollen wir wollen die
arbeitsplätze unserer kolleginnen und
kollegen erhalten das eisenbahnsystem
hat an anderer stelle wunderbare
tarifabschlüsse zustandegebracht exakt
mit den kennzahlen des öffentlichen
dienstes wärme trans der firmen netinera
gmbh mit go ahead haben wir
tarifabschlüsse exakt mit diesen werten
und wieso geht es bei
eisenbahnverkehrsunternehmen die auch
umsatzausfälle durch corona haben die
auf staatliche hilfen erhalten
warum geht es dort und warum geht es im
staatseigenen konzern nicht antwort
lautet weil eine umverteilung
stattfindet von unten nach oben und weil
die manager sich die taschen voll hallen
mit enormen summen mit enormer
altersvorsorge und den kleinen menschen
die wenigen euro wegnehmen wollen ich
danke ihnen nach berlin claus weselsky
werder chef der gdl zum neuen streik der
lokführer